hello everybody my name is benue Deja
I'm a machine learning engineer at
Google's Advanced Solutions lab if you
want to know more about the advanced
Solutions lab please follow the link in
the description box below there is a lot
of excitement currently around
generative AI a new advancements
including new vertex AI features such as
Chennai Studio model Garden genei API
our objective in these short course is
to give you a solid footing on some of
the underlying Concepts that make all
the gene AI a magic possible today I'm
going to talk about the encoder decoder
architecture which is at the core of
large language models we will start with
a brief overview of the architecture
then I'll go over how we train these
models and at last we will see how to
produce text from a trained model at
serving time
to begin with the encoder decoder
architectures and sequences sequence
architecture this means it takes for
example a sequence of words as input
like the sentence in English the cat ate
the mouse and it outputs cell to the
translation in French
the encoder decoder architecture is a
machine that consumes the sequences and
puts out sequences
another input example is the sequence of
words forming the prompt sent to a large
language model then the output is the
response of the large language model to
this prompt
now we know that an encoderror decoder
architecture does but how does it do it
typically the encoder decoder
architecture has two stages
first an encoder stage that produces a
vector representation of the input
sentence
then this anchor stage is followed by a
decoder stage that creates the sequence
output
both the encoder and the decoder can be
implemented with different internal
architectures the internal mechanism can
be a regular neural network as shown in
this slide or a more complex Transformer
block as in the case of the super
powerful language models we see nowadays
a regular neural network encoder takes
each token in the input sequence one at
a time and produces a state representing
this token as well as all the previously
ingested tokens
then this state is used in the next
encoding step as input along with the
next token to produce the next state
once you are done ingesting all the
input tokens into the rnm you output a
vector that essentially represents the
full input sentence
that's it for the encoder what about the
decoder path
the decoder tags the vector
representation of the input sentence and
produces an output sentence from that
representation
in the case of RNN decoder it does it in
steps decoding the output one docket at
a time using the current state on what
has been decoded so far
okay now that we have a high level
understanding of the encoder decoder
architecture how do we train it
that's the training phase
to train a model you need a data set
that is a collection of input output
pairs that you want your model to
imitate
you can then feed that data set to the
model which will correct its own weight
during training on the basis of the
error it produces on a given input in
the data set
this error is essentially the difference
between what the neural networks
generates given an input sequence and a
true output sequence you have in the
data set
okay but then how do you produce this
data set in the case of the encoder
decoder architecture this is a bit more
complicated than for typical predictive
models first you need a collection of
input and output text in the case of
translation that would be sentence pairs
where one sentence is in the source
language while the order is the
translation
you'll Feed The Source language sentence
to the encoder and then compute error
between web decoder generates and the
actual translation
however there is a catch the decoder
also needs its own input at training
time
you'll need to give the decoder the
correct previous translated token as
input to generate the next token rather
than what the decoder has generated so
far
this method of training is called
teacher forcing because you force the
decoder to generate the next token from
the correct previous token
this means that in your code you have to
prepare two input sentences the original
one fed to the encoder and also the
original one shifted to the left that
will feed to the decoder
another subtle point is that the decoder
generates at each step only the
probability that each token in your
vocabulary is the next one
using these probabilities you'll have to
select a word and there are several
approaches for that the simplest one
called greedy search is to generate the
token that has the highest probability
a better approach that produces better
results is called beam search in that
case you use the probabilities generated
by the decoder to evaluate the
probability of sentence chunks rather
than individual words and you keep at
each step the most likely generated
chunk
that's how training is done now let's
move on to serving
after training at serving time when you
want to say generate a new translation
or a new response to a prompt you'll
start by feeding the encoder
representation of the prompt to the
decoder along with a special token like
go
this will prompt the decoder to generate
the first word let's see in more details
what happens during the generation stage
first of all the start token needs to be
represented by a vector using an
embedding layer
then the recurrent layer will update the
previous state produced by the encoder
into a new state
this state will be passed to a done
softmax layer to produce the word
probabilities
finally the word is generating by taking
the highest probability word with greedy
search or the highest probability chunk
with beam search at this point you
repeat this procedure for the second
world to be generated
and for the third one
until you are done
so what's next
well the difference between the
architecture we just learned about and
the ones in the largely win models
is what goes inside the encoder and
decoder blocks the simple RNN network is
replaced by Transformer blocks which is
an architecture discovered here at
Google and which is based on the
attention mechanism
if you are interested in knowing more
about these topics we have two more
overview courses in that series
attention mechanism overview
and Transformer models and bird overview
also if you liked this course to that
have a look at the encoder decoder
Architecture Lab walkthrough where I'll
show you how to generate poetry in code
using the concepts that we have seen in
this overview
thanks for your time have a great day